hi for is on TV I'm Nick Gillespie and
I'm talking today with the president of
freedomworks Matt kibbe man thanks for
coming let's what is freedom works
trademarks is a national grassroots
organization we stand for pretty simple
principles lower taxes less government
more freedom but our job is to get
people to show up and demonstrate their
preference for those values to
politicians and two people in power what
stick armies role in Freedom Works dick
armies are chairman when he resigned as
Majority Leader in 2002 he joined
Freedom Works and he spends a lot of
time in the road he does a lot of op-ed
writing and a lot of speaking he was
speaking at the Tea Party and does he
also string lights electrical lights and
phone cables for you guys because they
do that in a former life yet it really
does just that talk about the Tea
Parties this is one of the most amazing
kind of social events it's at least as
big as the twilight movie mania of a
couple months ago or of the watchman we
have I've seen counts as high as 350,000
people nationwide go into tea parties
what what is that about and what's
freedom freedom works role in that I saw
an estimate just now that said there
were five hundred fifty thousand and I
actually think there's more than that
because this was a truly spontaneous
grassroots uprising although you guys
did help organize them yeah we were
totally involved getting getting it
started and getting various activists
engaged but this thing took on a life of
its own which is where the real power
and it was there's five hundred fifty
thousand people a thousand different
events across the country I was in
Atlanta with Dick Armey and there was
fifteen to twenty thousand people there
it's amazing i've never seen
constituency turnout for freedom like
this what is the message of the Tea
Parties the message was pretty despite
what the left has been saying about the
message the message was pretty simple it
was stop spending so much money stop
borrowing so much money and stop bailing
out people that were irresponsible here
is a question because people and
say the left has been really taking a
lot of pot shots at the Tea Party even
misses the point that actually the
mainstream media I mean truly people at
ABC CBS NBC MSNBC are really ragged on
the tea parties what are they missing
when they try and categorize this as
some kind of corporate top-down scheme
or some kind of dangerous right-wing
reactionary program I think they're
genuinely flummox that people are
showing up so early in the Obama
administration saying that we don't want
any more spending we don't want anybody
to bail us out we just want the
government to stay out of this so that
the economy can recover and FreedomWorks
where were you guys on on tarp the
original bailout or the the last days of
George Bush's presidency yeah we were
stridently against it and very much felt
like we were throwing ourselves in front
of the train in September when this
happened but people don't remember this
now but the first house vote was
trounced and everybody was surprised
everyone was shocked but that's where
this grassroots uprising started a lot
of Republicans a lot of conservative
groups were sort of in the tank
supporting a Republican president but
you know we weren't and met new people
weren't yeah the Washington Post had
right after the house foot they had a
bunch of editorial saying the
congressman voted against tarp against
the bailout we run American there were
problems and you guys were saying no to
the bailout what is what's the
alternative if we are in a financial
crisis what does freedomworks
prescription for getting the hell out of
this recession well the best thing to do
and you can look at history and see that
often the government gets in the way of
economic recovery you had the Federal
Reserve and you had a bunch of stupid
government policies creating a housing
bubble and frankly creating a financial
bubble that burst and now they're trying
to prop it up the best thing they could
do is just get out of the way and
they're doing the opposite they're
borrowing money they're taxing money
they're printing money and it's going to
sustain this recession and it's going to
keep people from recovering in this
economic crisis what's next for the Tea
Party phenomenon well we have suggested
that a national
march on Washington happen on sep tember
12 in fact there's a website called 912
DC com there's a number of events as an
event on july 4th but i think there's
also going to be specific legislative
battles where I'm getting one or two
senators to see the light a few
congressmen to see the light Obama's
budget there's a that's going to be hard
now that torture is outlawed right to
get these guys to see the light well I
tell you what a little bit of grassroots
pressure they think that's torture yeah
and they respond to it Matt kibbe why do
you hate America I hate it so much yeah
um these guys are in charge and 9-12 of
course that date is picked for that's
well there's a number of reasons first
of all it's Saturday and it turns out
that people that believe in freedom
actually work for a living also they
can't just take a week off and go
protest second it is after nine eleven
and there's going to be a lot of
interest in people showing up and paying
respects to the people that died in that
tragedy well thank you very much for a
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie